J'ai trouvé des chaussures
jetées
dans la rue
et je les répare, elles ont l'air presque
neuves. Les déchets d'un homme sont le trésor d'un autre.
Beaucoup de gens me connaissent pour mes phrases.
Quand je vois le téléphone, je suis dans ma zone
et je  cela vous aide également à économiser 150 dollars
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
J'ai commencé
des restaurations parce que mon fils
est autiste et il est généralement ce qu'il
veut,
il froisse la pointe des chaussures,
il les plie et j'ai trouvé une technique
où vous mettez une
chaussette  à l'intérieur de la chaussure
et tu portes une serviette tu mets la
serviette sur la
chaussure et ensuite tu la repasses je
ne savais pas ce que je faisais au début
mais pour économiser de l'argent
je devais le faire j'avais perdu mon emploi
auparavant  et je cherchais un
travail à la maison pour mon fils et je me suis dit tu
sais ce que j'ai réparé
les chaussures de mon fils, pourquoi ne puis-je pas commencer à
réparer les chaussures
pour qu'il soit en fait mon
inspiration pour la restauration
de mes baskets  ma sœur m'a invité dans une friperie de bonne volonté
et j'ai trouvé des chaussures pour huit dollars
et je les ai achetées et quand je les ai ramenées à
la maison, je les ai réparées et un de mes
amis m'a
vu avec des chaussures toutes neuves, des
Jordans neuves, il a dit combien
tu l'achètes pour homme, ce sont de si bonnes chaussures que
j'ai dit que je l'avais acheté à la friperie,
il ne pouvait pas y croire, il est comme si tu
savais que tu peux bien vendre ces chaussures et
je les ai vendues pour 150 dollars
et c'est de là que vient la phrase cash, je
pense  Je viens d'économiser 150 dollars mais
avec cet argent,
j'ai acheté plus de chaussures
et
j'ai commencé à revendre des chaussures. Je viens
d'une famille très pauvre, je n'ai jamais eu de bonnes
chaussures, tout le monde se moquait de moi, alors quand
j'ai enfin eu de bonnes chaussures,
euh, j'ai pris soin de moi.  d'entre eux et je voudrais
que vous les nettoyiez et
euh
chérissez-les parce que je savais combien
coûtaient les chaussures quand Kobe Knight a
frappé Kobe 19
et
ils ont fermé toutes les friperies,
ma restauration,
euh, mon
travail a été ruiné, je ne pouvais pas, je
pouvais  je n'ai plus de chaussures
et c'est à ce moment-là que l'idée du tic tac est venue
l'idée est venue de ma fille ma fille
Grace m'a dit tu sais quel
papa tu es un gars drôle
tu sais pourquoi tu ne l'es pas pourquoi tu ne fais pas de
tique-
Je n'ai jamais pensé
que
mes restaurations de baskets iraient à des
millions de personnes, surtout avec seulement
60 secondes où nous avons
atteint
le million.  abonnés
en peut-être environ trois mois, j'ai reçu
beaucoup de messages de beaucoup de
différents
euh nettoyeurs euh nettoyeurs de chaussures
et j'ai choisi eb kicks et je suis sponsorisé
par eux
et c'est comme ça que j'ai commencé à être payé
et euh
ça a rendu les choses beaucoup plus faciles et
et euh, fondamentalement,
j'aime faire ce que je fais maintenant,
maintenant je le fais à des fins de divertissement,
certaines des chaussures que je donne aux
gens, euh, nous faisons des tirages au sort
et c'est ma façon de
les rendre aux gens,
à mes abonnés que
je répare  les chaussures
avec mes mains nues
et c'est accessible aux gens, quelque chose
qu'ils
peuvent aussi faire, c'est une autre façon
de recycler et aussi de
nettoyer la terre
et je n'ai pas
peur de montrer aux gens
ce que je sais
parce qu'à la fin  du jour, le soleil
brille pour tout le monde et comme vous le
savez déjà,
quand vous voyez la mousse,
vous êtes dans la zone